does this keep happening to you that's
right well look no further because this
flight school video should help you
finance your pilot skills as well as
give you a better idea on what the hell
you're supposed to be doing in each of
the ships in Walker assault mode let us
begin the basic side note if you're on
PC I recommend you plug in a controller
frantically sliding the mouse is a chore
and it feels really dumb use a
controller great dogfighting more often
than not you're slamming on the brakes
the entire time while in a circle chase
against an enemy this will help you
tighten your turn inevitably putting
your bogey in the crosshairs
occasionally flaw tooling up and
changing directions help make you
unpredictable in turn confusing the
other dude but rinse and repeat these
moves and that's all you need to do
great if you got a bogey on your six
you're pulling the exact same turning
tactic when you got a missile locked
onto you there are two moves up your
sleeve roll left or right using the
d-pad but more often than not you're
using up on the d-pad to spin around
real quick and it typically shakes off
that homing missile you get for special
defensive abilities teams different tie
fighters and tie interceptors have a
swift speed boost be sure that you're
pitched up when using the boost to
prevent yourself and dive bombing into
the ground and looking like an idiot a
nice tactic here is to boost and spiral
up in turn giving you the high altitude
advantage rebels have a shield ability
if you have a missile locked onto you
throw it on if you're making a strafing
run and a TSD throw it on it recharges
quickly so use it religiously once it
got in your crosshairs hold that left
trigger to lock locking on to a bogey
will not only Auto off your lasers but
will walk on your homing missiles just
listen for that class of chime and let
them rip baby
another one down if you are imperial yes
you're taking out rebel air support
especially snowspeeders and Phase three
but when you're not you're pounding fire
on uplink areas and most importantly
when y-wings are inbound your goal is to
lurk in these areas here and shoot these
bombers down they come in fast so make
sure you're able to gauge their spawn
and distance yourself correctly rebels
obviously shoot down TIE fighters and
bump are at a TST but one of her y-wing
prompts occur we're goal is to lay down
fire on those 1880s save your proton
torpedoes for these guys whenever you
get a warning I mean that's your whole
team's purpose take those walkers down
and then of course there's the third
base when so speeders are thrown into
the mix get in one of these and lurk in
the canyon hiding from TIE fighters
until y-wing stun the walkers then you
strike if possible go for the Walker
farthest away from the hills it's out in
the open whereas the other one likes
Lindley right into the rocks
ouch attach that cable and using the
right stick keep that Medical Center
it's a bit tricky and may take you a
couple times to pull it off in just like
in the movie well that's all I got for
you I hope this basic guy taught you
something if you have any tips yourself
put them in the comment section below
you take care now bye see you later